всім привіт ми тут природно як і вся
країна обговорюємо одне це нові записи
з кабінету прем'єр-міністра гочі руках
де він говорить про те, що він повний
профан в економіці, що ми і так знали
що у нього немає жодного плану, що ми
теж знали але він ще одні ленському
каже що в нього порожнеча в голові і
туман але це теж всі знали дуже
новин немає як бачите це
депутати від слуги народу, які вже не
знають як їм бідним що сказати вони
би кращий звичайно корини ніж вони
обрали тих на профанів уряду та
що вони будуть робити з президентом з
туманному голові ну це їх не
вистачає а ось так якісь дрібні
пакості зробити та так от дивіться ось
цей момент коли ми це все слухаємо та
дивимося
надходить ось таке повідомлення всім тут
колегам дивіться купуйте квитки на
вечірній квартал квитки у гени та телефон
гени всі всім кому цікаво можете
геній зателефонувати, але взагалі хотів би всім
розсилати їм таких масок нагадати в нас
вже у всієї країни абонемент на 5 років
ваш вечірній квартал і вже такий сміх
крізь сльози
лунає з кожного куточка ось такі
справи хлопці це верховна рада України та
ось що ми обговорюємо і ось що ми маємо